hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is iphone 10 and it's my favorite iphone
ever by far and there's no doubt that in
the history of iphones this thing is
iconic it's more modern it finally feels
like a new iphone that's a big part of
why I like it so much but that's also
the source for a few sore spots there's
a learning curve to this phone unlike
any other iPhone you see every other
iPhone ever has just been home button
rectangle screen rounded corners pretty
much the same thing you note you're
getting yourself into you know exactly
how to use it and if there's going to be
one big new feature every year it takes
you two seconds to learn it and you're
good I phone 10 is different with this
phone there's maybe three or four big
fundamental changes to the way you use
the phone now it's very clearly still an
iPhone you still mostly know how to use
it but there's a couple things that are
different that you'll have to get used
to so on the outside is the shape we're
used to the rectangle with rounded
corners but this is the first time the
display itself actually has curved
corners and it's pushed right up to the
edges of the phone or at least closer
than they've ever been the commercials
make it seem a little more dramatic than
it actually is but hey it's 2017 phones
have small bezels that's just the way
they are now so in that way the iPhone
catches up and it pushes everything to
the corners and keeps all the
front-facing sensors in the knotch
that's forsaken not at the top it's
actually not that big of a deal but
we'll get into that soon just holding
the phone though it feels great I think
it's an awesome size but if there were a
bigger iPhone 10 plus I would totally
get that right now despite the larger
display the 10 is definitely closer to
feeling like an iPhone 8 then an 8 plus
it still feels like a smaller phone
compared to the others I've used and
also thanks to the stainless steel sides
it's definitely slippery and it's
definitely going to slide out of your
pocket at least once it happens to the
best of them and it's crazy the silver
it's so shiny and honestly we all know
your phone is never going to look as
good as it does fresh out the box unlike
the more matte finish of the previous
iPhone I'm not convinced this super
shiny finish on the iPhones rails is
going to last like this we've seen this
before in other products it definitely
gets chipped and scratched you probably
already know I usually go for a matte
black skin here which not gonna lie
still looks pretty good but deep brands
got something new for the 10 the grip so
like the name implies this thing is
supposed to be the best way to grip your
phone look for a full review of this
bumper later this month but I'll leave a
link below if you want to check this one
out a lot of people were asking about it
when I showed it in my Instagram story
but overall it's a pretty complete
hardware package as you'd expect from a
thousand-dollar smartphone you know it's
the speaker's even though they aren't
front-facing are still pretty good its
water-resistant which gives you some
nice peace of mind it has wireless
charging it's no headphone jack
welcome to 2017 but overall it's well
considered and well put together is it
now officially the most breakable iPhone
ever thanks to having glass on the back
yes yes the one part of the hardware of
this phone I actually really don't like
is the camera bump but not just for the
usual reason like rocking on a table
I've just kind of accepted that at this
point but because of the new orientation
a couple times I've noticed it's easy to
accidentally get your finger in the
photo or video you're taking just cuz
it's all up in the corner it might take
a couple days to get used to that and
stop getting your finger and the corner
of your shots but what's really become
the signature feature of the iPhone 10
these are on the front and it is that
notch up at the top of the display and
there are two camps with this number one
is I hate it it's ugly I wish it wasn't
there and number two is I actually don't
notice it anymore
and just like with the essential phone I
tend to fall more in camp number two
when you want to make a 20-17 phone and
you want to shrink the bezels you still
have to put all the front-facing sensors
all of the cameras and the IR blaster
and the depth sensor you have to put
that somewhere in 2017 some
manufacturers keep a smaller traditional
bezel to house it some try to go no top
bezel and put everything in the chin so
I'm try to minimize all the bezels and
use a sort of a cutout knotch Apple has
decided to go with a knotch and I don't
mind it in fact I literally don't even
think about it anymore in everyday use
now obviously when you're focusing on it
here as I'm talking about it and
highlighting it on video it's really
obvious you know the unibrow at the top
it kind of just becomes a part of this
iPhone tens character but you're never
really looking at it during normal use
like flipping through apps scrolling
through Twitter Instagram whatever it
disappears pretty quick now not
everybody feels this way clearly like oh
I've seen all the clever like hiding the
notch stuff all the apps and the
wallpapers and that I get that but
because this is Apple and because
they're stubborn and will never admit
that any of their solutions are anything
other than perfect they've come up with
the opposite solution which is embrace
the notch so in all their software and
all the software they'll promote is apps
that wrap right around that notch and
fill up the whole display that's what an
optimized iPhone 10 app looks like and
since this is a taller aspect ratio apps
will have to get updated to do this
developers will have to get on their
horse and actually put in the work and
update their apps to get them to fill up
the display like this and to be fair
most of the big-name apps are already
upgrading and embracing the notch like
apple wants but there are still plenty
that haven't updated yet and they'll be
obvious when you see them because
they'll have these big bezels up at the
top and the bottom kind of like you're
using them on an iPhone 8 again so
slowly over the next couple of weeks and
months all the apps you are using will
get updated to embrace that notch
whether you like it or not it just takes
some time probably the biggest change
developers have had to make to their
apps for a new iPhone since the
beginning so for the record the only
time I really think about that notch is
when I'm watching videos yes it gets
kind of awkward here because when you're
watching videos fullscreen the notch
will cut off some of the display some of
what you're trying to watch so if you
want to avoid that you can actually
double tap and it'll bring in the video
you're watching on this OLED display now
you have some more bezels but at this
point now the video you're watching is
so small you might as well not be
watching it on a bigger screen it feels
like the same size as the iPhone 8 so
this whole thing is the main reason why
I would actually want a plus size iPhone
10 anyway as for the rest of the display
it's great
Apple calls it a super Retina display I
just call it their first OLED in a smart
phone ever finally and it's it's pretty
awesome it's a 5.8 inch panel high pixel
density it supports the p3 color gamut
HDR it has true tone it doesn't get as
bright and saturated as Samsung's like
no 8 and s8 displays but it is still
bright enough not too cartoonish with
the colors has a small blue shift when
you tilt it off axis but so do many
other Oh LEDs to varying degrees and it
still has 3d touch although I pretty
much stopped using that completely
except for lock screen controls that I
wish I could change so the screen is
awesome and it's a big part of why this
phone looks so good from so many angles
so a good job Samsung now of course when
you go to a full screen display like
this you lose the home button so that's
why iPhone 10 replaces that home button
with whole bunch of gestures this is the
biggest learning curve of any iPhone
ever but it's still not that bad you
swipe up from that bar at the bottom of
the screen at any time to go home now
anytime you see that bar it represents
the home and whatever app you're in will
close itself just like any other iPhone
hitting a home button swipe down from
the top for notifications but now swipe
from the right corner for your control
center and for multitasking again you
have no home button so you swipe halfway
up and then over to get through your
recent apps that'll get you to that same
card style carousel as before but
overall once you get hang of this system
once you get used to all this swiping
which took me a couple days it felt
pretty natural I actually started trying
to swipe up on other phones which shows
you how weird how much I got used to
that the one that took me the longest
was multitasking because I started off
thinking you had to swipe up then wait
and then the cards show up but that
always felt so slow but what you really
have to do to get this to work is you
swipe up and over and I gets you to the
cards way faster so that's a pro tip for
anyone who is still swiping up halfway
and waiting for the cards to show up
like I was you're welcome and for those
with small hands or who just really
liked reach ability on the bigger iPhone
you technically still have it here it's
buried in the accessibility settings but
you can do the little swipe down on the
bottom of the screen to bring the top
corners within reach and that makes
getting a top gesture is easier with one
hand I leave that on it's pretty useful
sometimes now of course the other big
change that comes with ditching the home
button on iPhone 10 is he also just
ditched that fingerprint reader which
means as you may have heard they needed
to replace that with face ID facial
recognition face ID on the iPhone works
really well most of the time it's not
perfect and I think touch ID was close
- perfect as far as fail rate goes but
it's still impressively good here I
talked about how touch ID is like the
gold standard for quickly and securely
getting into your phone in the previous
video I'll link that below the like
button of course and I still believe
that touch ID is definitely still faster
but face ID can get better with software
updates and with time as millions of
people begin to use it I think that'll
happen and it still also has some
physical limitations that you can become
aware of and avoid just like touch ID
had some physical limitations that you
could become aware of like when your
fingers wet or it doesn't quite work
because of stuff on your hands or if you
have a glove on stuff like that you just
know touch IDs not gonna work so you put
in the passcode face ID has some
physical limitations - it works by
bouncing thousands of little infrared
dots off your face and back into the
sensor and creating a map of your eyes
nose and mouth
it doesn't actually use the front-facing
camera and it can learn a changing face
over time it still recognizes you when
you get a haircut or shave a beard or
put makeup on none of this stuff has a
huge effect on the dot map that made of
your face it also won't be tricked by a
picture of you because that doesn't have
the depth of your face and I can also
work through some pairs of sunglasses
again the ones where the infrared light
can get through but face ID has been
known to fail when you're backlit or
when there's like a ton of extra
infrared light coming in basically from
the Sun it's like how a dim flashlight
doesn't work when it's really bright out
same thing face ID is gonna get blinded
by all that extra infrared light just
gotta type in your passcode but those
times for me were few and far between
if touch IDs success rate was 99% to me
it felt like face IDs success rate was
like 95% now I can add up when you
unlock your phone hundreds of times a
day but again this can get better as it
gets used more there's even some
settings as well where you can turn
attention on so it won't unlock if
you're just holding the phone up to your
face not only that but you have to be
looking at your phone then it'll unlock
and show all your notification data
works pretty well for me just please
don't do this while driving and even if
face ID is this workaround - not getting
the fingerprint reader underneath the
glass in time for this phone I still
think that at its best facial
recognition on a phone is closer to
secure seamless authentication than a
separate fingerprint reader ever would
be because with this you
just pick up the phone and it works you
use it you login you pay for stuff you
download apps etc but if someone else
picks up your phone it won't work it's
that simple
and then there is an emoji possibly
maybe the most fun feature of iPhone 10
but you know it's hilarious these moving
facial tracking and emoji are iPhone 10
exclusive you can't get this on any
other iPhone so if you get one of these
then you know the person that sent it
has an iPhone 10 and weirdly enough if
you send this to someone with an Android
phone they just get a video message of
this an emoji but here's the thing an
emoji is just using the front-facing
camera check this out an emoji is
working and continues to work even when
you cover the depth sensors and the
extra front-facing sensors all that
stuff it'll work when you cover
everything except for it the
front-facing camera which means they
totally could have made these available
for any other iPhone but they didn't man
an emoji is the classic I have an iPhone
and you don't feature classic Apple
iPhone 10 also has some slightly new
cameras same exact sensors for both
cameras as the iPhone 8 plus but
slightly better glass and now both are
optically stabilized so this is gonna
get you some meaningfully better
performance with the 2x telephoto lens
and zoomed in photos and zoomed in
videos things like that which is good to
see because I avoided using it with
previous iPhones and as you'd expect
photos from the iPhone 10 look awesome
I'm especially happy with how much
dynamic range we're getting HDR on
previous iPhone cameras used to be a lot
less aggressive and I kept asking over
and over for a little more a little more
and now photos really pop the sky is
like always so blue details their color
accuracy is tight it's not as good as
the pixel twos camera just gonna say
that right up front but this is a top 5
smartphone camera and no doubt if you
want a video sample check out the Tesla
rap video I'll link it below that's 5
minutes of 4k video from the sensor
right there if you want to watch that
and despite his tendency to overexpose I
think it might be the best front-facing
camera for video for any smartphone
they've also added portrait mode to the
front-facing camera for portrait selfies
on the 10 but it doesn't work nearly as
well edges get blurred super hard almost
to a comical amount when compare it to
something like the pixel
- or even the back facing camera but the
thing is pixel - does all this so much
better because of machine learning and
software so in theory iPhone 10 can keep
learning and get this good - plus it
already has better color accuracy so
I'll be on the lookout for that software
update now you may have noticed we've
made it all this way into an iPhone
review without talking about any of the
specs shows how important that is
but iPhone 10 is rocking the a11 Bionic
chip and three gigs of ram and it's
awesome in fact it's really really good
I would say this is the most powerful
mobile chipset in any smartphone right
now the benchmarks are insane but this
isn't for iOS this is for all the things
that run on top of iOS the augmented
reality apps the image processing the
super slow-motion video all of that
stuff at iOS is still iOS as you know I
mean it obviously feels more modern
because of all the swiping and the
gestures now but as far as functionality
it has all the same stuff and features
you're used to has all the same quirks
are used to like iOS this notification
system is still a mess since they don't
group apps together this is still easily
fixable but there's plenty of other
things I wish would be different about
iOS - but it's Apple
they're stubborn you'll get used to it
and battery life on the iPhone 10 has
turned out to be pretty great close to
the iPhone 8 plus I would say again
iPhone is a champ of standby time and it
always has been so no problems there and
it handles the biggest iPhone display
ever pretty well thanks to it being an
OLED I haven't had any problems getting
to the end of a single day with full use
if you want to use that screen on time
metric it's usually around 6 hours so
the bottom line and the question that I
get the most often about this phone is
so what do you think and if you made it
this far in the video you already know
what I think but in case you skipped to
this part this is my favorite iPhone
ever by far I really like it
is it worth $1000 honestly I don't think
people spending the money on this phone
will be disappointed now that's not to
say this thing is perfect it clearly
still also has its downsides you know
the fact that it's all glass on the back
more breakable that's a downside the
notch on the front for a lot of people
that's a downside no headphone jack
still a downside but those are all
things that I think people who are
buying this phone are already used to or
were expecting
and for that reason it's not a
deal-breaker in 2017 so I'm happy to be
carrying this phone so if you were
thinking about going out and getting
this phone go ahead I think you'll like
it too until the next one there's been
mkbhd thank you for watching
tuffsy as the next one peace
[Music]